>>> ONLY ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
WE ARE SO PSYCHED TO REVEAL THE
2021 NATIONAL TEACHER OF THE
YEAR.
EXCEPTIONAL EDUCATOR, SHE IS OR
HE IS, CHOSEN BY THE NONPROFIT
COUNCIL OF CHIEFS STATE SCHOOL
OFFICERS.
THIS YEAR'S FINALISTS INCLUDE
TEACHERS FROM UTAH, WASHINGTON,
D.C., NORTH CAROLINA, AND
NEVADA.
LOOK AT THAT LIST.
I REMEMBER WHEN WE PROFILED
THESE GUYS.
AND THE 2021 NATIONAL TEACHER OF
THE YEAR, DRUM ROLL, PLEASE,
TONY AND ANTHONY --
JULIANA URTUBEY OF LAS VEGAS!
>> YAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THERE SHE IS.
LOOK AT YOU.
AS MS. EARTH.
SHE USES A GARDEN TO TEACH AND
CONNECT WITH HER STUDENTS.
MANY OF WHOM ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
JULIANA URTUBEY IS WITH US.
CONGRATULATIONS.
STAND BY FOR JUST A SECOND.
WE'RE GOING TO COME RIGHT BACK
TO YOU.
FIRST, WE SPOKE TO SEVERAL OF
YOUR FORMER STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE DONE,
THE DIFFERENCE YOU'VE MADE FOR
THEM.
>> I WOULD DESCRIBE HER AS KIND
HEARTED, ALL KNOWING, FUN, YET
ALSO SORT OF SERIOUS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR BEHAVIOR.
>> SHE'S KIND, AND SOMETIMES SHE
TELLS US A JOKE.
>> SHE WAS A GOOD LEADER, AND
SHE WOULD JUST TEACH US LIKE
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAT
OTHER PEOPLE WOULDN'T.
>> SHE WAS ALSO A TEACHER THAT
CARED A LOT.
SHE DIDN'T JUST SEE THE STUDENTS
AS STUDENTS.
SHE SAW THEM AS MORE THAN THAT.
>> SHE ALWAYS REMINDED ME OF
MISS FRIZZLE FROM "THE MAGIC
SCHOOL BUS."
>> GOOD MORNING, CLASS --
>> SHE EVEN HAD THE LITTLE
EARRINGS THAT MISS FRIZZLE HAD.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I LOVE
THE MOST IS I LOVE LEARNING IN
THE GARDEN.
>> THE GARDEN GNOMIS WAS THE
NAME BACK THEN.
>> IT FELT LIKE A DREAM.
THERE WERE BUTTERFLIES AND LADY
BUGS.
>> I THINK THIS CHANGED MY LIFE
KNOWING WHAT COULD BE DONE WHEN
IT COMES TO TAKING CARE AND
PROTECTING OUR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMICAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> WHO TAUGHT YOU THAT?
WHERE DID YOU LEARN THAT?
>> SHE SHOULD BE LIKE THE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT A GREAT TEACHER
SHOULD BE.
>> SHE WAS THE BEST TEACHER.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> SHE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING, TAKING CARE OF ALL
THE KIDS AND LOOKING OUT FOR
EVERYBODY.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> WOW.
>> JULIANA URTUBEY IS BACK WITH
US.
GOOD MORNING, AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU, MS.
URTUBEY.
LISTEN, IT'S CLEAR THAT TEACHERS
CAN CHANGE THE WORLD, CHANGE
LIVES.
THE STUDENTS CLEARLY LOVE YOU.
WHY DO YOU -- WHY DO YOU LOVE
TEACHING SO MUCH?
>> I GET TO BE PART OF A WHOLE
NEW WORLD WITH SO MANY STUDENTS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN SO MANY OF THOSE
STUDENTS IN SUCH A LONG TIME.
SO IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
I'M JUST SO EXCITED.
>> I KNOW.
BUT LOOK -- LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE YOU'VE MADE IN THEIR
LIVES.
AND THIS HAS BEEN A REALLY
CHALLENGING YEAR FOR TEACHERS
THIS YEAR.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP AND STILL
DOING IT?
>> IT REALLY HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE, AND THEY HAVE MADE
THAT SAME KIND OF IMPACT IN MY
LIFE.
IT'S BEEN TOUGH.
IT'S BEEN A HARD YEAR.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF
LOSS.
>> YOU HAVE.
>> AND WE'RE HERE, THOUGH.
WE'RE HERE, AND WE'RE DOING
WELL.
AND WE'RE DOING OUR BEST TO STAY
CONNECTED.
>> WELL, LISTEN, WE'RE NOT THE
ONLY ONES THAT WANTED TO
CONGRATULATE YOU.
WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL GUEST FOR
YOU, IF YOU COULD PUT YOUR MASK
BACK ON SO WE CAN FOLLOW SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THEY'RE GOING TO
COME IN THE ROOM.
>> OKAY.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO COME IN THE
ROOM.
THEY WANTED TO BE THERE
PERSONALLY TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> OH, MY --
JULIANA URTUBEY, MEET DR. JILL
BIDEN, DR. JILL BIDEN, MEET
JULIANA URTUBEY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO BREAK.
GET THEM SOCIALLY DISTANCED --
>> THIS IS -- OH MY GOODNESS.
>> WE'LL PUT A MIC ON DR. BIDEN
SO WE CAN HEAR WHAT SHE SAID.
>> SHE SAID CONGRATULATIONS.
>> SHE CAME WITH FLOWERS.
GUYS, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK, AND WE'LL COME BACK WITH
A CONVERSATION.
>> MY GOSH --
>> WONDERFUL.
>> DR. BIDEN AND JULIANA
URTU